everyone and welcome back to the
Peterson Institute for international
economics I'm Adam Posen the institute's
president and it's my pleasure and our
institute's honor to host MP Rachel
Reeves the shadow Chancellor of the
exchequer and MP for Leeds West since
2010 from the UK
um
many of us remember 20 and 30 years ago
the
desire among various center-left parties
including the Democrats in the U.S and
labor in the UK to try to find the
so-called Third Way
or other such terms and there was a
group which had electoral success doing
that
uh since then a lot of that program
uh which frankly a number of people in
this building were part of
um has been repudiated by various parts
of the left more so in the U.S than
elsewhere as neoliberalism to be
replaced by a new
form of economic thinking
um I'm not putting the ideological
burden on Missouri's shoulders she is an
intellectual leader and a policy maker
likely to be and most importantly a
working politician so such empty
Concepts may not matter to her
but in the period of the last several
weeks we've had important speeches by
U.S treasury secretary Janet Yellen
National Security adviser Jake Sullivan
unusually on economics we hosted here
about two months ago uh Lawrence Boone
the minister for Europe from France who
articulated her vision obviously for
speaking for the French government on
where they might go in terms of the
intellectual orientation for dealing
with China in the insecure world over a
year just over a year ago Christine
Lagarde gave a speech on that and so in
this intellectual ferment of dealing
with how to make a progressive and just
policy that's sustainable in a scary
world it is our privilege to have Rachel
Reeves come to us come to Washington and
make her statement of how and the UK
labor party are thinking about these
issues
um
Missouri is going to give a speech a new
business model for Britain building
economic strength in an age of
insecurity
uh we will follow that by a few
questions for me and then open it up to
our in-person audience we welcome all of
you online as well
um just to recap
Rachel has been the MP for Leeds West
since 2010 the rare trained economists
who actually put herself out there as an
electoral candidate
um she's currently Shadow Chancellor of
the exchequer she served in a number of
front bench Shadow roles for the labor
party
including Shadow pensions Minister
Shadow Secretary of State for work and
pensions and Shadow Chief Secretary of
the Treasury as well as something that
does not translate shadow Chancellor of
the duchy of Lanchester uh Lancaster
excuse me
um prior to being an MP Rachel worked as
an economist at the bank of England as
well as being seconded to the British
Embassy in Washington where a number of
us got to know her in both those roles
she also in her copious free time is an
author
and has a book I believe coming out in
this fall
the women who made modern economics a
personal history
we will now hear from Rachel Reeves with
her main hat on which is making Economic
Policy Rachel thank you for joining us
foreign
well thank you Adam for that
introduction and thank you very much to
the Peterson Institute for hosting me
here today
I first came to Washington as you said a
little over 20 years ago as a young
Economist at the bank of England I was
seconded to the British Embassy here in
Washington to analyze the American
economy
in Britain that was a time of prosperity
and progress with wages and productivity
Rising
little did we know then that within a
decade things would change so
dramatically and now under successive
conservative governments progress
stalled wages flatlined and prosperity
turned to stagnation
not long ago I met a mum and dad in a
town called Worthing on England's South
Coast
between them they held down five jobs
juggling work with the responsibilities
of child care and they struggle to make
ends meet
as a family they spend just half a day a
week together
but while they give so much
they get such little in return
and they live in a world where those
most basic of hopes
time together as a family
buying their own home
saving for a decent retirement
all feel painfully distant
and one thing about that conversation
will always stay with me
because the mum and Worthing said
something that I will never forget
she said
you just wonder if you are doing
something wrong
well she isn't doing something wrong
but something has gone wrong in our
economic system
our economy no longer works for working
people
their contributions are no longer
respected their Enterprise is no longer
rewarded and even their most ordinary of
hopes seem like impossible Dreams
today I'm going to talk about how errors
in economic policy making allowed
Britain's economy to weaken
how the long hard years of austerity and
the chaos of recent governments have
compounded that change
and how Global shocks explode expose our
weaknesses with devastating consequences
for working people
but I'm also going to talk about
approach an approach which I call
secureonomics that can right those
wrongs
by drawing on the talents and efforts of
millions of working people in all parts
of our country by forging a new
partnership between an active State and
dynamic open markets
by fostering a new era of global
Partnerships between nations with shared
values and shared interests
all with the goal of making hard work
pay for working people in Britain once
again
now Britain has incredible strengths the
second largest exporter of services in
the world Europe's leading Financial
Center homes are some of the world's
most dynamic businesses at the very edge
of possibilities with world-leading
universities that are expanding the
frontiers of human knowledge
but today's inflation numbers for the UK
show inflation remaining stubbornly High
and the imf's forecasts this week show
that the UK is still expected to have
the highest inflation in the G7 this
year and our long-term growth showing
little signs of improvement after a
decade or more of weakness
have Britain's immense potential is
being wasted
at the root of this I believe are two
errors in economic policy making
the first of these is what I consider to
be a fundamental under appreciation of
the role of government
that error dictated as a government's
primary economic imperative should
simply be to get out of the way of free
enterprise
in the early in the 80s and the early
90s this meant cutting taxes and
stripping away at regulation and
addressing only the most egregious
market failures
Advocates of this approach believed that
Wells would trickle down
but while wealth was generated
there wasn't much trickling
instead we witnessed a steady flow
upwards
meanwhile whole industries were allowed
to decline or disappear whole
communities were thrown on the scrap
Heap with no alternative work to pursue
and public services and Social Security
were weakened by a Thousand Cuts
the second error flowed from the first
it was the assumption that the people
and places that matter to a country's
economic success a few in number
this misconceived view held at a few
Dynamic cities of a few successful
Industries or all that a nation needs to
thrive
in Britain this meant that the southeast
of England could Forge ahead while the
city of London has a few other
Industries would power our economy
the result was a paucity of ambition for
too many places
the hollowing out of our industrial
strength and a tragic waste of human
potential across vast ways of our
country
the new labor era overlapping with the
new democrat era here reversed some of
these trends
during a period in which Britain
experienced faster growth than many of
our competitors including France Germany
Japan and Italy labor turned Prosperity
into progress
Public Services were rescued from the
point of collapse investments in
education it dramatically improved
educational outcomes
and a focus on older and youth
inequalities saw a million pensioners
and children lifted out of poverty in
Britain
but a progressive politics built for an
era of strong productivity growth and
increasingly frictionless trade
did not have the answers for the world
economy after 2008.
the glass labor government did
understand that which is why after the
financial crisis it worked to develop a
more active State providing industrial
strategy in Britain
and the results are evident today the
seeds of our successful Life Sciences
industry which has blossomed into a
truly World leading sector were planted
by labor in that period
but 13 years ago the conservatives
returned to power in Britain and we
dramatically changed course
first came the brutal austerity that
followed the financial crisis where our
Cuts in spending were far deeper and far
faster than our International peers
demand was sucked out of the economy
and investment the lifeblood of economic
growth stagnated
and for all the bitterness of the
medicine
the patient got no healthier
even before covid struck government debt
was nearly 30 percent higher than it had
been 10 years before
and after austerity came the chaos
first we had brexit without a plan
introducing pervasive uncertainty into
our economic life
next came The Madness of Liz truss's
drive-by Premiership
which since our guilts markets tumbling
and saw quasi-quarting the then
Chancellor dashing out of an IMF meeting
here in Washington to be sacked by the
prime minister
today under Rishi sunap we have a tired
Administration out of ideas
and while we were promised sound
management it feels more like managed
decline to me
held back by these two errors of policy
making weakened by 13 years of austerity
and then chaos Britain has been buffeted
by a world as has become increasingly
uncertain
we're now living through what I consider
to be an age of insecurity
in just the past few years there have
been three events that might easily be
described as once in a generation
if not once in a lifetime
first Britain's chaotic departure from
the European Union then the worst
pandemic since 1918 and finally Russia's
invasion of Ukraine bringing major
conflict to the continent of Europe for
the first time since the Second World
War
in the years ahead
the pace of change offers little hope
of letting up
a rising China is unbalancing the old
Global Order of a unipolar world
climate change presents Our Generation
with its greatest moral and economic
challenge
and new technology threatens to upend
everything about how we live and how we
work
in this new world we have discovered the
limits of globalization
we have seen that Supply chains that
prioritize only what is cheapest and
fastest
struggle when a crisis hits
be that PPE during covid or energy
following the invasion of Ukraine
we have discovered that A globalized
system can be gamed by countries like
China who have undercut and ignored
international trading worlds and made it
impossible for our own to compete
and in the process
we have allowed the production of
critical Technologies to slip from our
grasp
costing us jobs and compromising our
security
to witness Britain today
is to witness a country buffeted by
global forces
with our industrial capacity hollowed
out fluctuations in international
markets hurt us more than most
with wages low and demand suppressed our
growth is anemic
twenty years ago the average Britain was
wealthier than their European Neighbors
today the average French family is 10
richer than their British peers
in Germany that figure Rises to 19
percent
and in Britain the old model is failing
in an uncertain world we cannot rely on
a handful of Industries for our economic
success
nor can we Outsource the supply of
critical goods and services to the
lowest bidder
confronted by the challenges we face in
the years ahead no government can simply
get out of the way of the market
and no democratic government can be
content with a lack of decent work and
falling wages
and the dimming of people's hopes for a
better life
to do so is to betray the people we were
elected to represent
and risk spanning the Flames of populism
as our countries know only too well
that's why it's time for us to admit
that globalization As We Knew It Is Dead
we must care about where things are made
and who owns them we must Foster new
Partnerships between the free market and
an active State and between countries
across the world who share values and
interests
this Demands a new approach
one that I call secure anomics
it focuses on the economic security of a
Nation
prioritizing economic strength and
resilience in the face of our uncertain
world
addressing the challenges of the future
and finding opportunities within them
it also focuses on securing the finances
of working people
good jobs decent pay
strong public services and an end to the
Relentless increases in the cost of
living
I'm in Washington today because while
the old Washington consensus might have
been swept away a new one is emerging
Tarts is what treasury secretary Yellen
has called modern supply side economics
the Biden Administration is rebuilding
America's Economic Security it
strengthened its resilience
a more active State pursuing a modern
industrial strategy is selecting the
areas where America must guarantee its
ability to produce what America needs
whether that's in digital technology
through the chips act or in clean energy
and Industry through the inflation
reduction Act
your government is working in
partnership with a dynamic open market
where the state does what the government
does best making and shaping markets
that are essential to America's
resilience and future Prosperity
meanwhile the free market does what only
it can do
innovating competing creating wealth
this acknowledges the reality of our age
and the economic necessity of resilience
it is a rejection of the hyper
globalization of old but it is also an
invitation to Greater partnership
between those countries that want to
address the challenges and seize the
opportunities of tomorrow together
across the world others are following
suits the Albanese administration's
powering Australia plan
Schultz's climate and transformation
Fund in Germany macron's visit vision
for economic sovereignty in Europe
you might well ask
Warrior reaction has there been in
Britain to this changing world
well my opposite number Jeremy Hunt the
current Chancellor of the exchequer has
made his position clear he considers the
Biden Administration to be engaged in a
distortive global subsidy race
speaking at Davos earlier this year
Grant shaps Britain's Energy Secretary
called the policies dangerous
well what is dangerous is sitting on the
sidelines while other countries Forge
ahead
I can promise today that a labor
government would be different
earlier this year Kia stama announced
that labor will be guided by a set of
missions
the first of which is to secure the
highest sustained growth in the G7
with good jobs and productivity in all
parts of the country
now I know how ambitious this sounds
especially after our performance these
last few years
but that does not deter me because I
know we can build a prospectus for
economic Prosperity that allows Britain
to embrace the opportunities of the
future
built on the rock of financial stability
and Economic Security
with labor Britain will Embrace secure
anomics now that won't mean trying to
make Britain a version of America
Australia Germany or France because we
know that won't work
don't mean becoming a better version of
Britain
by building on the existing strengths of
our economy our expertise in energy and
Life Sciences are Professional Services
and creative Industries are World
leading universities are enterprising
and industrious people
and also by strengthening our economy
when we must become more resilient
rebuilding the industrial foundations
that we have lost and which have left us
exposed to shocks
investing in the industries and
technologies that will determine our
future economic success
and building Financial Security in each
and every household in Britain
with good jobs decent pay and fair
working conditions to ensure that
working people can contribute to our
national success
and that their Financial Security
underpins our economic success
today I have published a paper that sets
out how a modern supply side program
would deliver secure anomics for Britain
it sets out how a new industrial
strategy can identify those areas where
the UK can and must thrive
it shows how an active strategic state
will work in harmony with vibrant open
markets
and it shows how we can build the
industries and create the jobs of the
future in the industrial heartlands of
the past
that means cyber amongst the former coal
and steel communities of South Wales
Robotics and AI in business hubs in
lancashire's Mill towns and carbon
capture and storage Technologies
pioneered and applied in manufacturing
areas such as teesside
through Labor's green Prosperity plan an
initiative I first announced 18 months
ago we will make public investments in
the industries that are crucial to
Britain's future success
a new National wealth fund will invest
in Britain's Industries and provide a
long-term return to the taxpayer
GB energy a new public Energy company
will invest in the clean energy sources
of today and of tomorrow
throughout we will use public investment
to underpin and unlock further private
investment just as the inflation
reduction act and chips act have done
here
and we will remove the barriers that too
often stop investment like Britain's
ludicrous planning system
and the reason this matters so much is
simple
jobs
in every industry that we are building
or rebuilding in Britain it is the jobs
that matter
decent jobs in every part of the country
jobs that pay well putting more spending
power in the pockets of working people
jobs that mean that a young person who
wants to get on in life no longer has to
get out of their hometown
jobs that workers in Britain are
equipped with the skills to do
and just as the Biden Administration has
done here we must build the industries
of the future in partnership with both
unions and employers delivering all of
this demands that we remove the barriers
that currently hold people back are
particularly acute problem in Britain
today
this means expanding affordable child
care helping women get back into the
workforce
fixing Britain's struggling Health
Service to get millions off of the sick
list
making sure that we have the right
employment support and reforms to
support getting more people back into
work
and improving vocational and education
training to equip people for the jobs of
the future
when looking across the pond to Biden's
Administration Britain's current
government sees a subsidy arms race
in a fascinating recent speech that Adam
Posen also mentions National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan answered this
question directly
he showed that while globalization as we
know it may be dead a new era of
multilateral partnership is emerging in
its place
I agree
Nations who share values and concerns
and who want to seize the opportunities
of tomorrow
can and must work together to boost our
Collective resilience and security
it is a signal achievement of Britain's
recent government but it has managed to
be both too open and too closed
to open in Latin Britain's industrial
strength hollow out
and too closed in the barriers to trade
it is erected through its chaotic brexit
deal
a modern supply side approach in Britain
would see us rebuild our industrial
strength but it would have trade and
partnership at its heart too
Britain with labor will be a trading
Nation exporting across the world and
open to business and investment at home
Britain cannot should not unlabor with
labor will not try to go It Alone
in 2025 the UK's deal with the European
Union is up for review
while there's no going back into the
European Union the single Market or the
Customs Union with labor we would make
trade easier with Europe and rebuild our
ties with our closest Neighbors
in the last few years the British
government has set another critical
relationship slip
in his recent remarks the U.S national
security adviser mentions a number of
international Partners Canada the EU
career Angola Taiwan Brazil I could go
on
but one country to me at least was
notable by its absence
Britain
a relationship once called special has
been allowed to wane
with labor that will change
labor will build a new special
relationship and it will be a green
special relationship
focusing on the clean energy economy
where both Britain and America have
signature strengths
as any visitor to Britain will tell you
we are blessed with more wind than
almost any other Nation
and so we have the second biggest
offshore wind capacity of any country in
the world
we have the potential to lead the way in
new technologies like green hydrogen and
carbon capture and storage where our
unique geology provides us with storage
capacity 500 times the UK's entire
annual carbon emissions
working together we can guarantee a
resilient supply of clean energy and
technologies that will power the UK for
decades even centuries ahead
in this process
we can bring down bills create good jobs
and strengthen our energy security
time inflation and build on our long
history of economic collaboration
today a Rolls-Royce engine built in
Britain but fitted to a Boeing plane
manufactured in America
is sold in one recent sale but worth 34
billion dollars to India's national
airline
the green technologies of the future
offer new opportunities to power
whether that's Rolls-Royce engine
running on sustainable aviation fuel
or Britain's pioneering work on floating
offshore winds deployed in the Deep
oceans of the Pacific West Coast
by establishing a nationwide network of
climate export hubs a labor government
would Place Britain at the heart of the
global Supply chains in the key
Technologies of the future
this is a new multilateralism without
without the excesses of hyper
globalization
this is the promise of secureonomics
I believe in a better future for Britain
it is one where our businesses are world
leaders
where Britain has a leading role in the
industries that will Define all of our
futures
powered by the contribution and efforts
of millions of working people
so rather than expecting wealth to
trickle down we ensure that to borrow a
phrase wealth is built from the bottom
up and the middle out
if labor wins the next election I intend
to be a very different Chancellor to my
recent predecessors
in one sense I know that I will be
like treasury secretary Yellen America's
first female treasury secretary I will
break a glass ceiling that has been
placed for too long in Britain by
becoming Britain's first ever female
Chancellor of the exchequer
I will chart a new course for Britain
it by wins by accepting that the world
has changed and that Britain must change
with it
in our age of insecurity
we have discovered the weaknesses of our
old economic model
too unambitious about the role that an
active State can play too willing to
believe that wealth will trickle down
and to reliant on the contribution of
too few number of Industries and too few
people
From the Ashes of hyper globalization
secure anomics emerges building the
industries that guarantee Britain's
Economic Security
forging resilience at home while
creating new Partnerships abroad
and bringing together an active state in
partnership with a vibrant Market
secureonomics means that a mom and dad
in Worthing
or in Wyoming who are doing the right
thing
no longer feel like they are doing
something wrong
but more than that I can start to take
advantage of the enormous opportunities
in our economies
this is the true promise of secure
anomics
security that provides the foundations
upon which we can build hope
hope as a nation knowing that our future
can be brighter than our past and hope
as individuals knowing that we can get
on not just get by that we can provide
for our families and pursue our
Ambitions whatever they are
while this may seem like the most
ordinary of Hope
it's being Out Of Reach for too long
for too many
with labor in power that will change
because from security comes hope thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you shout out Chancellor Reeves uh
you did pick up on the
Broad
new take
since we're the Peterson Institute for
international economics
before opening up to our audience if we
may can I press you a bit on some of the
economic aspects of your program and
some of the international aspects of
your program
so
I frankly
think the analysis Bears out your point
about the austerity since 2010
of successive UK Tory governments being
a problem
uh I argued against it when I was in the
UK as a policy maker at that time
but you didn't mention some of the very
real challenges that do the UK does face
on the fiscal front the long-term
underpayment of health care workers and
some other workers in the public sector
the breakdown of Transportation
infrastructure
demographic shifts that affect all our
countries
High income countries
on other stages you have spoken about
the need for fiscal discipline and you
made some mention of financial stability
how
are you going to manage this
admittedly very difficult hand you've
been left to play how do you set the
budget priorities in that situation
uh well thank you thank you for that
question Adam and for engaging uh so
much of the work that I've been doing
an incoming labor government will face
an economic picture
which poses a lot of constraints and it
means that an incoming labor government
will not be able to do everything that
it might want to do not as quickly as it
might want to do it we're going to be
left with a debt to GDP ratio of around
90 percent the highest tax burden in 70
years
inflation well we'll see where it is by
the next election as of this morning you
know 8.7 in the most recent numbers the
IMF are forecasting growth of 0.4 this
year which the current Chancellor
welcomed as a huge sign of success
simply because the economy is no longer
forecast to shrink well you know my
ambitions are a lot higher than that but
it the fiscal constraint is which is
what you focused on in your question
um Adam are very real now last year in
the so-called mini budget from prime
minister trust and Chancellor quateng
tried an experiment of unfunded tax cuts
and that did huge damage to the
reputation the global reputation of
Britain and it did huge damage to family
finances and and economic security in
Britain because as I mentioned in that
speech you had that huge turbulence in
guilt markets and now people are paying
what I describe as a Tory mortgage
penalty when they come to remortgage
their homes this is just a timer around
two and a half million people will
remortgage their homes this year on
average they'll be paying something like
300 pounds extra a month so the lesson
that I take from that is the fiscal
discipline is just incredibly important
and I'm not going to make any unfunded
tax cuts or spending increases and I've
said the everything in our Manifesto
from the labor party be fully costed and
fully funded because you can't have any
plans for economic growth unless you
have that rock of economic stability and
financial stability and you mess with
that at your peril and that does mean
that difficult choices will be have to
made but similarly the answer of just
going for more tax Rises I just don't
buy that either because one of the
things that's choking off economic
growth in our country with the highest
tax burden in 70 years the last Labor
government managed to improve living
standards and improve Public Services
because it did what the conservatives in
the last 13 years have failed to do
which is grow the economy and that's why
Kia Salma and me have said that the
number one mission of an incoming labor
government is to get that economic
growth Because unless you have that
economic growth you won't be able to
invest in public services or improving
living standards so that for me is the
key Focus thank you and and you and the
leader of the opposition as well as some
of your colleagues on the shadow front
bench have been talking about your
mission to secure the highest sustained
growth in the G7
um
again there there was a lot of
work already done and a lot of over hype
about deregulation as a path to growth
so that is probably not where you want
to go
um but realistically getting growth up
is hard when
as you mentioned there was a Slowdown of
productivity growth across the holy oecd
um 20 years starting roughly 20 years
ago
so in that context first
what do you think is the reason that the
UK seems to have had the biggest
sustained fall
in productivity growth
compared to its peers
and second
um
how big a difference do you think
the investment in energy life sciences
and a couple of the other key Industries
you mentioned how just order of
magnitude what will that do for growth
what will that do for employment so in
terms of why the performance in the UK
has been so much worse than um our peers
I put it down to the two errors that
identified
um towards the beginning of the speech
the first error is that a growth comes
from a small number of people in a small
number of parts of uh the the country
you don't really need much industrial uh
strategy
um uh and the second area sort of flows
from the first the the best thing that a
government can do is get out of the way
now I think that the opportunities but
also the challenges that we Face
requires a more active and a strategic
State working in partnership with
business but also with allies
internationally to secure those
opportunities you know there's a global
race on for some of the jobs of the
future carbon capture and storage a
green hydrogen a floating offshore wind
some of the examples I gave him my
speech now I think there's every reason
to believe that Britain can be a world
leader in those sectors but at the
moment other government moments around
the world are putting much more effort
into getting those jobs and those
investments in Britain than we are in
the UK and I gave the example of of of
floating offshore winds and wind energy
in my speech because in some ways it's
been a massive Britain's British success
story with the second biggest producer
of wind energy in the world but for I
think it's every megawatt of offshore
wind energy produced in the UK we create
0.5 jobs in Denmark it's 5.5 jobs the
reason is that they had a strategy in
Denmark to capture the supply chain do
the manufacturing do the research and
they've got the jobs but we assemble
them at host the wind farms but we're
not making uh the uh the technology and
we're not making the uh the manufactured
goods so that's why we need an
industrial strategy with government and
business working together to see some of
these opportunities to get the jobs I
don't want us just producing the energy
and want us to get the jobs that go
alongside it and that's the Insight that
I take from what the Biden
Administration are doing as well
um and the international Dimension as
you said is something I want to come
back to in a moment but I want to pick
up on something which I know has been a
sincere concern of yours for a long time
as as well as a front order issue for
your party which is the issue of
regional divergences de-industrialized
regions versus the city of London things
like that
um and only literally the city I mean
the region
um this is not unique to Britain the U.S
has had uh has
um
has regions states localities that have
fallen way behind France despite as your
mention of them outperforming in GDP per
capita they have huge Divergence between
Paris and the South
um the historical record whether in
China Italy Germany of trying to catch
up backwards in the sense of economic
opportunities regions is not great
um
what do are the lessons you take about
what's a successful policy since you
you've spoken about that goal and
there's been a lot of recent talk about
directing the Pension funds and
potentially a British Bank
um towards that goal could you say a bit
more about what you have in mind
so we've set out the mission to have the
highest sustained growth in the G7 but
how growth is generated and also how it
is shared really matters to me so good
jobs and productivity in all parts of
the country matters you know you could
have a model of growth where you know
London and the southeast further
diverges from the rest of the country
and created great wealth and prosperity
and then you redistribute that in some
way to other parts of the country but
talent I believe is evenly distributed
but opportunity in Britain is not there
are many opportunities in some parts of
the country and very few in others and
so at the heart of the modern industrial
strategy and the green Prosperity plan
the care and myself are setting out is
about how to rejuvenate Revitalize
re-industrialize some of those towns and
cities that have been left out and left
behind by a hollowing out of industry
and the great thing about some of these
jobs and opportunities of the future in
carbon capture or floating offshore wind
is those jobs aren't going to be in
London and the southeast they're going
to be on the east coast of England and
Scotland uh but by the North Sea they're
going to be in those towns that led the
first Industrial Revolution in Britain
and that's really exciting because it
will allow people wherever they live in
the UK to fulfill their potential and
contribute and have the Dignity of a
good job that pays a decent wage with a
sense of purpose you mentioned the issue
about Pension funds look we've got a
real challenge in in Britain and this is
you know a something I was talking about
with people in New York a couple of days
ago that a startup and scale-up
businesses in Britain when they're
looking for pre-seed and Seed funding
and then the different uh funding rounds
often struggle to raise that capital in
the UK and they look across to the US
and start raising that Capital here and
then when that company gets to the point
where they want to list and they look at
listing in London or look at listing in
New York and more and more are choosing
New York and it's even worse than that
you've got companies that are already
listed in the UK that are de-listing and
re-listing in the US and that poses a
real challenge for the UK because we
want to keep that wealth and keep those
jobs and those diffusion of ideas within
Britain otherwise we're going to miss
out on some of our own homegrown talent
and so Lord Jim O'Neill
um who was former Goldman Sachs and was
a minister under David Cameron and
George Osborne for the conservatives did
a review for my party on how we can make
Britain the best place to start and grow
a business and one area where I think
there is real potential is unlocking
money from UK paint Pension funds at the
moment pension Savers in the in the UK
have got something like
um two trillion pounds in defined
benefit pension schemes and half a
trillion in defined contribution schemes
and yet very little of that is invested
in UK listed and unlisted equities if
just a small fraction was that would
give a huge amount of growth Capital
long-term patient capital for those
Innovative businesses and it would
generate a higher return for pension
savers who do very badly actually on
pension returns in the UK so that's one
way in which we can try and unlock
capital for some of those fast-grown
businesses keep more jobs in Britain and
generate better returns for people
saving for their retirement thank you
um turning to the international side two
questions before we open it up to the
floor
um
a lot of what you've described in terms
of wanting things that are listed in New
York to be listed in London
jobs that are in Denmark to be shifted
to jobs in the UK
um these are frankly zero some
um and
a month ago we had the prior to Yellen
and Sullivan's speeches we had the
Indian Finance Minister sitting where
you were sitting where you are now
sitting and she was praising very
heavily usdr Ambassador Ty's policy
saying this is great this is what we
want to do we want to do subsidies we
want to put up tariffs we want to make
sure goods sold in India Are Made in
India
if we play out this game
of subsidies
and and favoring domestic located firms
and ownership and production you said
globalization is dead we must care about
where things are made and who owns them
if we play out this game does the UK as
a non-member of the EU and not a union
with the US end up well off
I totally understand your challenge and
I'm certainly not suggesting a retreat
uh from trade but I think it has to be
different and I think that Security's
got to be at the heart of it you know
where things are made and who owns
things does matter and I think that has
been revealed by some of the shocks to
the global economy these last few years
but as I hope I made clear in the speech
and no new multilateralism can emerge
from the hyper globalization of the past
with stronger Partnerships between
countries whose values and interests are
shared but I also don't accept
that it is a zero-sum game the
International Energy agency says that
five trillion dollars a year needs to be
spent on getting to Net Zero over the
next 20 years even with the size of the
inflation reduction Act
all that money is not going to come to
the US every country in the world needs
to be investing in these new industries
of the future and there are plenty of
jobs to go around as we make that
transition to a net zero economy but we
have been too reliant on countries like
China like Russia and Elsewhere for
critical things energy supplies and
semiconductors
and in the interests of our security we
need to think again about those things
so it's not a retreat from trade but
it's about doing things differently in
the interests of our Economic Security
and also the security of working people
um
thank you for that relatedly though not
directly
um one of the few things that I think
most
fair-minded economists say the
succession of opposite of your opposite
numbers in the UK government have gotten
right in the last few years is that
they've made non-eu immigration
work you you've the UK has ended up with
on net
roughly the same amount of immigration
maybe a little more
um this has come in areas that where the
UK had shortages of Labor like health
care and certain professional skills
um
obviously you're not Shadow Home
Secretary but you're a member of the
front bench and your Shadow Chancellor
um usually this kind of immigration is
good for government balance sheets
whatever else is involved
how do you see immigration and the
non-eu or high-skilled immigration going
forward
so businesses complain to me regularly
that they struggle to recruit the people
with the skills that they need uh and
and therefore want to bring in more
workers from overseas but at the same
time the size of the labor force in the
UK has fallen since the pandemic got
something like two and a half million
people who should be at work who are not
working because they are off on
long-term sick they're struggling uh
with um child care and older people's
care you know because some of our
crucial Public Services aren't working
properly too many people are kept away
from work and so a modern supply side
approach will also require fixing our
NHS and getting people off the sick list
and helping some of the the people who
are currently absent from the labor
market back into it and we also need to
do much more to skill up people already
in Britain to do the jobs that are
available particularly the high pay AIDS
and high skill jobs and I think we do
turn in Britain too quickly to
immigration to fix skill problems rather
than training people up in Britain so of
course we've got to make sure that
businesses can access the skills that
they need to succeed I want to keep
those businesses in Britain but
government need to do much much more to
expand the existing labor market in the
UK and ensure that people have the jobs
to do those the skills to do those jobs
thank you and and just to remind
everyone the government of the late
prime minister Abe in Japan with women
nomics as opposed to secure economics
by investing in those kinds of things
increased labor force participation by a
few million women so
this is a vision I can certainly share
um let me open it up to the floor please
uh if you're near the front raise your
hand and Jessica can bring you a mic if
you're towards the back please go to the
standing mic and no matter how famous
you are or how well you know our speaker
please identify yourself when asking a
question
please
okay
of course
thank you
in the way in which you discussed the
last Labor government uh and I would
love you to talk about the relationship
of your project in pure stormers to the
new labor project because you seem to be
saying at the same time on oh thank you
you seem to be saying at the same time
on the one hand there were great things
that happened under that old labor
government but there were things wrong
with it I wanted to ask what was wrong
with it and does that come from just a
change in circumstances or from some
rethinking at the level of theory and
practice and thanks again
well thank you very much for um coming
along this morning EJ
the last time that labor won from
opposition was 26 years ago 1997. you
have to be older than 70 in Britain to
have voted for a labor prime minister
that's not called Tony Blair uh so Tony
Blair is the most successful leader that
the labor party has ever had and in the
13 years that labor was in government
under Tony and then Gordon Brown had
transformed Britain for the better
um our Public Services were on then he's
when they became prime minister and
Chancellor and they rebuilt them and our
economic growth averaged between two and
two and a half percent between 97 and
2010 it's been about 1.4 percent in the
13 years under the conservative
governments that have um that have
followed so I have huge respect for what
Tony Blair and Gordon Brown did
but it was 26 years ago and the
challenges we Face the global
environment and the environment at home
are just so different you know if you
think about the big challenges we Face
globally the rise of China
Russians Russia's behavior in Europe the
challenge of meeting the climate
emergency
those things just weren't on the agenda
when Tony Blair and Gordon Brown uh held
the reins all those years ago so I think
there's a huge amount that we can learn
from what they did I want to rebuild the
public services that the conservatives
have decimated these last 13 years I
want to get that economic growth but the
way in which we do these things is
different to the way in which they were
able to achieve them 13 years ago so
they had the right answers I believe for
the time but there's got to be different
answers to meet the challenges of today
thank you
um so Jessica what first preference goes
to our external guess not not internal
um so Jessica that woman uh the
gentleman back there if you could go to
the standing mic and then the woman in
the orange jacket please
thank you I'm Katie Stallard from the
new Statesman can I just press you a bit
on where China fits into this vision of
secure economics um in the last few
weeks we've seen the UK Investments the
UK investment Minister travel to Hong
Kong to I think quote re-engage there
seems to be an interest in restarting
economic and trade dialogue would a
labor government take a more skeptical
approach to China and do you envisage
hewing closer to a U.S approach of you
know restrictions on critical technology
restrictions on Chinese investment in in
critical industry it's a great question
um we're getting close to When Rachel
has to leave so if the gentleman who
raised the tank could go to the mic will
just gather the question thank you thank
you thank you very much Adam secretary
thanks so much for your speech my name
is Emmanuel Adam I represent British
American Business we incorporate the
American Chamber in the UK and the
British chamber in the US we are
apolitical but let me say that many of
the points you made in your speech take
a lot of boxes now and your policy
agenda so we look forward to this
question
the question is um you drew a lot of
comparisons between the industrial
strategy that you propose with um what
the buyer Administration is doing right
now
um the one thing that the by
Administration gets criticized for
sometimes from the business Community is
a lack of a bold trade policy you said
that Britain would be a very active
trading Nation so the question is how
would you have your industrial strategy
go in par with an active trade policy
thanks so much thank you very much and
the last question uh Claire Healy with
e3g it was music to my ears you talking
about the Net Zero economy being the
driver of this modern industrial growth
strategy if you could elaborate more on
the US UK green special relationship
what that looks like practically and
does that invite in other countries such
as India Etc
uh thank you very much for those um
those questions shall I yeah
um so first of all um Katie on China
I I think it would be a mistake to to
cut China out of the global economy and
would cause huge damage as well to
countries like Britain and the US that
still trade very significantly with
China but I don't think we could be
naive about the way homes in which we
trade and I don't think we can
compromise our economical National
Security and big errors have been made
in in the UK
um allowing the Chinese uh to be so
close to our nuclear energy program
um in the UK
um nearly allowing them to uh to run our
telecommunications infrastructure those
are mistakes and when we must never make
those sorts of mistakes again so yes
trade but we also need to protect those
areas that are crucial for our economic
and our national security and that is
one of the lessons that we need to learn
and that's one of the reasons why I say
globalization
um uh as we know it is is there heads
the hyper globalization of the past but
a new period of multilateralism between
countries whose interests are shared
will become more important than ever and
I guess that leads on really to the the
second question about the trade policy
and the point I made in the speech about
Britain both at once being too open and
too close too open and that we've
hollowed out vast sections of our
economy and too closed in that we've put
up unnecessary barriers in terms of
trade with our uh neighbors and biggest
trading partners in the European Union
now there's no going back into the
single Market or Customs Union that ship
has sailed but we can build closer
relationships uh with our European uh
neighbors again so for example I would
like Britain to have a Veterinary
agreement with Europe which would
improve the flow of a food and farming
products uh between our countries I
would like to secure the mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications so accountants lawyers
Architects Etc who are trained up in
Britain will have their qualifications
recognized as they were before in Europe
I would like to help our fantastic
creative and cultural Industries in
Britain by reducing some of the red tape
and bureaucracy around visas for touring
so there are practical things that we
can do to improve trades uh with our
neighbors and and trading partners and I
guess then linking to the third point
about the the green special relationship
because clearly an area of growth in
terms of jobs and production is going to
be in the clean energies of the future
and it's an area where because of
Britain's industrial Heritage because of
our geography because of our great
existing businesses and The Innovation
coming out of our fantastic universities
we've got huge strengths and we believe
with the right policies Britain could
become a netex border of energy by the
middle of the next decade but none of
these things will happen by chance which
is why I talk about a more strategic and
agile State working with businesses and
working with Partners abroad to uh to
seize these opportunities and I think
it's one of the real synergies between
what you are doing here in the US and
what I want an incoming labor government
to do in the UK to learn from what is
happening in terms of stimulating those
Industries in clean energy in the US
doing that in the UK and then trading on
the basis of of those opportunities and
yes of course there will be Global
opportunities there as well but the
close links for example
um are the already exists I gave the
example of of
um of Aviation that is an industry it's
going to go through huge profound change
in the years ahead as we move to a net
zero economy there's already a huge
trade relationship in that area how can
we move that forward so it's a green
relationship a green special
relationship uh in the in the future of
course we would look to that with other
countries but I think they're real
synergies and close Partnerships that we
can build on between the UK and the US
thank you so much for doing three
questions in two minutes
um and more broadly for sharing with us
your vision on the labor party's vision
for UK economic future as part of the
global assessments around globalization
industrial policy and growth